did the diabetical by message Coach Pep
Guardiola gave me the chills all over my
body and if you're a leader or you want
to be a great leader I think this is
going to give you a completely different
perspective on leadership if you get
value from this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel so let
me tell you what happened the other day
my sister has an Instagram account
somebody got into her account hacked it
stole it started selling Bitcoins I'm
getting messages with my sister on
Instagram said hey you got to buy this
Bitcoin you don't even believe how much
money I make I'm like what the hell is
going on here so I sent a message to her
and eventually I just bought a Tesla I
bought this about that and they message
all our people just because somebody
hacked into her account this is why
today's sponsor is Aura because identity
theft has officially passed rivalry as a
number one crime in America there is a
website through Aura imagine a one place
to protect all your family for identity
theft where you can go and search how
many of your passwords are on a dark web
test a couple of our employees here did
it 43 passwords 41 of them 38 of them if
you haven't taken advantage of what or
offers right now I highly recommend
protect you and yourself I'm America's
fastest growing crime Tri Aura free for
two weeks and see if any of you or your
family's personal information has been
compromised start your 14-day trial at
aura.com forward slash pbd you can click
on the link above to get started with
aura here's what the quote was I tried
making Messi the best player in the
world but he ended up making me one of
the best managers in the world pretty
wild code right when you think about
that I try to make Messi the best player
in the world he may be one of the best
managers in the world aren't you the
leader aren't you the coach like you're
supposed to do that to me he's not
supposed to do that to you but that's
the mindset of somebody that thinks they
have the responsibility of knowing it
all you have to be the leader of
everything you know how many times I've
had interactions with my kids where
they've challenged me I'm like whoa that
was very interesting what just happened
right there how many times I've had
conversations with the people I work
with I'm like that was a very good point
of view that was a very interesting
thing so somebody may say oh wow so what
you're saying is the fact that Messi was
his coach that's why this quote is so
powerful but this guy has his own resume
stacked as an individual leader watch
his resume by the way what he's done he
holds the record for the most
consecutive League games won in La Liga
in Bundesliga and Premier League he was
a former player he was named the FIFA
World coach of the year he won four
Premier League titles four efl cups the
FA Cup a domestic trouble in 2018-19 at
37 years old he became the youngest
manager to lift the UEFA Champions
League trophy this isn't the history
ever he was the youngest to do it so
again he's not a lightweight coach this
is a guy that stacked with his resume
but if you watch him when he celebrates
Messi scoring there's this famous video
where Messi scores the goal and he's
just sitting like a proud father
celebrating with his son saying wow it's
so awesome to be working with this but
I'm curious about that quote is he
saying it because Messi made him a great
coach or is he saying it because a
handful of players were so difficult so
annoying with such a big upside that he
had to work 10 times harder to move them
until all of a sudden one day a message
showed up and he's like man I have to
spend 100 hours on these guys but I just
have to ask Messi this thing one time
and he wants it so bad and some of these
guys were just as capable but they just
weren't mentally willing to pay the
price like this guy's willing to pay the
price to make it to the highest level a
coach becomes grateful for great players
only if he's had a lot of challenging
difficult personalities he work with so
you ought to be as grateful for these
guys as you are for these guys in my
career I got four kids now some of the
things my kids do that's annoying and
it's challenging like you know you get
cornered you don't know how to handle it
I go all the way back to a handful of
personalities I've worked with in the
last 20 something years of leading sales
people and businesses and I'll say man
you remind me of that guy back in 2004.
you remember about that guy that one guy
in 2008 that was very hard to work with
in that six-month stint which you just
did reminds me of what he did but I know
how to handle it because that guy
coached me you know what you just did
right now son you don't even know what
I'm saying under my mind I've gone
through this 17 times with other people
that was my training to become a great
parent those difficult people I work
with challenge me to become a better
leader today so it's not all about the
people you work with that are easy
sometimes if your goal is to be a great
leader somehow someway God or whatever
Spirit you believe in is going to put
some interesting people in your life
that will force you to say I don't even
know how to work with this guy
everything I do is difficult with this
person why are these people so difficult
well maybe that's your challenge to see
if you're willing to up your game throw
on how to move this person because the
great leader is either going to say yep
I'm willing to invest in this person
because there are shown signs of
greatness or no I'm wasting my time
nothing else is going to happen here
because the attitude is that bad they
lack gratitude they think they know it
all they're difficult to work with I'm
simply needing to move on and fire this
person you're firing this customer this
client this individual and say I just
can't save this person and I'm going to
move on and find somebody to work when
you're going to say now I realize well
I'm so grateful for this person maybe
the quote for me was deeper than an
average person that reads it or I read
this quote I'm like oh my God I found
somebody in the company that I work with
so put two thousand and uh 15 I've been
in the business since 2001 15 14 14
years later I hire somebody that we work
with it's a palace I couldn't believe
how easy they were to work with I didn't
turn these guys into leaders they were
leaders but you work with them in your
life I just watch them look at this guy
look what they're doing look what
they're so awesome so great looking are
doing this is so amazing but I have to
go through this to be grateful for
people like this that make everybody
else better as a leader if that's your
goal you're going to go through it as
well it's going to be a wild ride so if
you appreciate the quotes it's probably
because it hits you the way it hit me as
well at the current phase you're at so
if you enjoyed this video I got another
video I want you to watch is 10 traits
to develop As Leaders if you've never
seen that click here to watch it take
care everybody bye bye-bye
foreign
[Music]